hey there thank you for being here
especially if this is your first time
with us Adventist or otherwise tonight
we are circling back around to the camp
of an SDA Pastor by the name of Jeff
dowel the pastor of Hastings SDA Church
who was seeking to refute a two-part
presentation I gave titled in defense of
the first day Sabbath in part one of our
response to him we saw how Mr Dow's
criticisms were entirely nullified based
on the simple fact that he entirely
misrepresented and misunderstood what
was said this is a fact I'm not going to
rehash everything from part one so if
you missed that you can go back and
check that out the link is in the
description box down below however I do
think it's valuable to refresh you on
Jeff's Central objection in part one as
well as in the presentation that Jeff
was critiquing I showed this chart
wherein I was giving a Redemptive
historical analysis of the doctrine of
the Sabbath I began by explaining how
the Sabbath is a doctrine that to truly
understand one must look at the entirety
of scripture from Genesis to Revelation
which is why my presentation began in
Genesis where I pointed out how Adam and
Eve were not present on day one of
creation this was important because in
Jewish tradition it was customary to
count a day from the evening until after
the sunset the following day one such
proof of this can be found in an article
in the conservative Judaism Journal
where we read quote in the Jewish
tradition it is customary to count the
day from the onset of night until after
the sunset of the following day this
method of counting was based upon the
language of the Bible in the creation
story where it says says several times
and it was evening and it was morning
the first 2 3rd Etc day close quote and
this is part of what my chart was
seeking to visualize based on evening to
evening Adam and Eve's first day would
have been the seventh day of the week
the sunset of the seventh day closing
out the first day of their existence
which would mean that Man's first day
was God's Sabbath day the seventh day
the day that he ceased from the work of
creation now like I said I've explained
this chart more fully elsewhere but I
made it very clear in both part one as
well as the presentation that Jeff
decided to misrepresent what exactly the
chart was seeking to convey but instead
of representing it accurately Mr Dow
tried claiming that my position and
claim was that man's existence brought
about a new week that was different from
God's week such that the seventh day was
Saturday for God but Sunday for Adam and
Eve therefore I'm injecting a first day
Sunday Sabbath his words into the
Genesis account as I showed in part one
this is not only silly but it's not even
close to what I claimed but one last
thing before we get back into it I want
to remind everyone that the focus here
is not necessarily to convince you of
the Christian Sabbath position if I were
seeking to do that I would go about
things in a different manner in this
series we are focusing on examining Mr
Dow's criticisms along the way there
will probably be many things that you
disagree with but my hope is that it
will help clarify the difference between
what Adventists are claiming and what
historic Christian sabari believe
leaving you better informed even if you
leave disagreeing with that in mind
let's pick back up where we left off in
part
one so how then according to the weekly
cycle the seven days in their order are
determined from a first day Sunday
Sabbath when each day is determined by
the seventh day Sabbath not not the
first day of the
week I'm going to talk about Romans 14
no one day in seven determine the weekly
CLE of each day in its order I just pick
whatever day you want that doesn't
determine the weekly
cycle only the true seventh day from
creation determines the weekly cycle in
each day of the week from creation even
till
now nowhere in the Bible can you find
where the week is governed by the first
day of the week as called by the critics
Sunday
Sabbath based on these key words this
Theory concludes that Sunday is the New
Order of sabbaths according to a New
Creation we're going to be talking about
that in this video some tonight and in
the remaining
videos this new creation is something
that Miles says Adventists have no clue
about listen to what Dell ratler
says first there are no planned first
day of the week meetings as if Christ
had told his disciples before his death
to meet on the first day of the week
rather the disciples were taken by
surprise now don't you think Jesus would
have hinted to his disciples now after I
die we're going to go back to the
original first day Sunday Sabbath in
creation that's going to be the Sabbath
that Miles says Jesus
restored and yet D ratf admits well
Jesus never said anything about any of
that
before his
crucifixion so according to Dale ratov
Jesus never Jesus never said anything to
his disciples before his death about
this new
creation
Sabbath by the way Dale rat even changed
what he says in his different
books the regular practice of Christian
worship on Sunday came many years after
the death of Christ not at the
resurrection
he says the regular practice came many
years after the death of
Jesus and then in his other book he says
the regular practice of Christian
worship on Sunday came as a
voluntary celebration of the
resurrection of Christ tackle that one
miles look at that carefully Miles
because he says it's a voluntary
celebration so was that first Sunday
Sabbath in Genesis a volun AR
celebration or was that something that
God commanded or was that something
that just
happened yeah I don't have to tackle
anything Dale rats said Jeff because
Dale rats wasn't a Christian sabari he
doesn't speak for me I don't know why
you were bringing up all these other
people in this presentation this is one
of those silly instances where an
Adventist thinks that all former
Adventists that disagree with adventism
hold to identical positions in the part
particulars and we don't now I know that
Adventists love to jump on this and this
is probably why Jeff brought other
people into the mix because then they
say well if you don't agree in all the
particulars look how divided you guys
are huhuhuh you're only United in your
hatred of adventism yeah good
obfuscation good deflection away from
from what's in Focus we might arrive at
the same conclusions but that doesn't
mean that we use the same Pathway to get
there the fact that Jeff can't see this
only further Reveals His unfamiliarity
with what he's criticizing despite his
insistence like we saw last time that my
apologetic is worse than bad remember he
said if this is the best apologetic
against the SGA Church's position I'd
hate to see what bad is yeah okay buddy
but he asked don't you think Jesus would
have hinted to his disciples that now
after I die we're going to go back to
the original first day Sunday Sabbath in
creation Jeff your question is built
upon your faulty misunderstanding of
what I believe and what I said in my
presentation you're about to make a big
deal in a little bit about me saying
that Adventists read the word Saturday
into the Genesis account yet I also say
that Genesis doesn't say Sunday
either so why did you keep claiming
throughout this presentation that I said
Genesis presents a first day Sunday
Sabbath I thought you knew the position
you're criticizing Jeff you said you'd
known about it for decades I want to
remind folks that in part one we heard
Jeff point out that I cited John's
Parker's book the Sabbath transfer a
book that Jeff claims to have owned for
30 years so he knows the position he's
anal I izing he told us however he
didn't bother to engage with Mr Parker's
exegetical work of Acts 13 and show why
it's flawed he simply said this to make
it appear like he understands what he's
criticizing and he's known about this
for decades nevertheless what did I
point out about this book in part
one the title of the book itself the
Sabbath
transferred which clearly means Mr
Parker and Christian sabbatarians are
not claiming there was a first day
Sunday Sabbath in Genesis we believe the
Sabbath was transferred to the first day
by virtue of God in Christ entering his
rest on the first day in the new
creation he had accomplished the work of
redemption he ceased that ended the
first day when he walked out of the Tomb
just like God in the original creation
act entered his rest the seventh day
after accomplishing that Mighty work and
that's precisely what I showed not only
in part one but in the presentation that
Jeff is critiquing speaking in the
original creation act God did a mighty
miraculous work he accomplished that
work in full and then ceased from that
work on the seventh day where he entered
his rest hence why the Sabbath in the
old creation was the seventh day it
memorialized when God entered his rest
but then that creation fell into sin at
the hands of the first Adam however as
Paul tells us in Romans 5:14 the first
Adam was only a type of the one who was
to come Jesus Christ the second
Adam the second Adam came and redeemed
the creation that the first Adam broke
what we could call a recreation
paralleling God in creation meaning the
Genesis account God in Christ also did a
mighty miraculous and creative work he
accomplished that work in full and then
ceased and entered his rest after its
completion but unlike God in the
original Creation in the Redemptive
creation God in Christ entered his rest
the first day the Resurrection Day which
was when that work was finished this is
what Hebrews 4 is saying as I have
presented many many times and believe to
be the most faithful interpretation of
that chapter but I've also shown how the
Suter for example prophetically foretold
of a new day I've shown how Psalm 1824
this is the day that the Lord has made
is applied by Peter in Acts 4 to the
Resurrection Day the day the new
creation was inaugurated and God entered
his rest after that better creative work
because yes the Redemptive creation was
superior to the original creation of the
physical matter like I showed in part
one with a beautiful explanation from
Thomas Watson in the original creation
God gave us ourselves but in the new
creation God gave us himself in the
original creation we have life in Adam
Romans 5:12 but by Redemption we have
new life in Christ Colossians 3:3 and 2
Corinthians 517 and there are numerous
other parallels like this in scripture
showing the Lesser to the greater and
how the Redemptive creation was superior
to the original creation of the physical
matter so Jeff can bck and scoff all he
wants and make it appear like Christian
sabari have this bizarre and Confused
understanding that's just totally silly
and wacky but it's only because what
Jeff is critiquing isn't what Christian
sabari believe it's a caricature that he
has made up that he is now trying to
saddle us with what is called a straw
man and if he actually knew his stuff he
wouldn't be acting like what I believe
is that bizarre considering all of his
Adventist Pioneers all of them stole
their Sabbath arguments from my
spiritual forefathers even the 7th Day
Baptist who the ainst were influenced by
they got their arguments from my
Christian forbears Christian sabari
which reminds me make sure you pay very
close attention to this next
section listen to what mil says the
quotations is what miles says if you go
to this video and watch it you'll see
exactly what I'm talking about by the
way what's really good about this is you
see I don't have to guess what they're
saying because when I watch their video
I just put it on Clos caption and it
shows you their very words that they're
saying close
caption here's what miles says Genesis
lays out a pattern it does not say
Saturday they read that into the text so
he's saying Seventh Day Adventist read
into the text of Genesis that that that
seventh day is
Saturday that's what he
says
so are Adventists wrong about the first
week of creation ends on
Saturday are they wrong that God rested
on the seventh day Saturday cuz he's
saying see we read Saturday into the
text so we'll just ask the question so
for those who are going to write down
the answers to these
questions answer the
questions I want to repeat it s adventus
wrong about the first week of creation
according to his Paradigm right there it
is the top that's not mine that's miles
and Dr casers that's not mine that's
theirs God's week first seven days so
our adventus wrong about the first week
of creation ends on Saturday are they
wrong that God Ted on the seventh day
Saturday do tell us miles if the first
day that God created the world is Sunday
what day of the week is this first day
in creation so I'm asking miles
ketton which of these days in God's week
is Sunday there's seven days not 8 9 10
first week of creation so I'm asking
miles tell us
miles if the first day that God created
the world is Sunday what day of the week
is this first day in
creation what day is
it where does Sunday fit into this
pattern that God laid down in creation
miles what do you read into this text
about Sunday there's only seven days in
the weekly cycle that occurs from
creation
so tell us miles is Sunday in this first
week of creation God's week is it in
God's week it's only seven
days which one of these seven days in
God's creation week is
Sunday which one is
it is this where Sunday
belongs oh let that soak in let's stop
for a moment un let's ask the question
again is this where Sunday
belongs Jeff this might have been one of
the most embarrassing parts of your
presentation clearly evidencing that you
either didn't actually listen or you're
a dishonest man there are no other
options maybe you should have listened
instead of relying on Clos captions or
maybe your reading ability is as bad as
your listening is so for starters you
didn't fully State what I said when I
talked about this had you done so Jeff
you'd realize why your supposed test
questions are entirely irrelevant I'm
going to answer them all with a single
clip from the presentation that you're
responding to Doug that verse shows the
pattern of the command six working days
followed by a Sabbath it doesn't say
Saturday doesn't say Sunday doesn't say
Sunday doesn't say
Sunday he assumes his Roman Calendar
influence and imports that into the text
failing to see that what's in view is a
pattern ah ah so I said the text doesn't
say Saturday or Sunday Jeff or Sunday
gee I wonder why you left that part off
could it possibly be that it's because
your entire presentation was built on a
straw man that I claimed Genesis teaches
a first day Sunday Sabbath and if you
would have correctly reiterated what I
actually said that would have disproven
your entire thesis showing that you're a
dishonest
person if I said the text doesn't say
Saturday or Sunday that once again
proves I didn't claim what you've
claimed I did about a first day Sunday
Sabbath in Genesis which is the
fundamental assumption that all of your
objections have been levied
against it's also why your alleged
brainbuster questions are completely
irrelevant my entire point of getting
the day names out of the way was for a
very specific purpose which I explained
and will do so again my entire point in
bringing up the week being a pattern as
well as the names Sunday and Saturday
not being present in the biblical text
was because I was showing how the order
of the creation week was not arbitrary
it was God teaching us something and we
can see this as Redemptive history
begins to unfold which is why I showed
Exodus 16 to talk about one such example
of this day six was Israel's preparation
day Israel had to follow instructions
regarding preparation day which is where
they had to prepare themselves before
they could enter into Holy Communion
with god well was this arbitrary or not
why why did God have them follow this
order why day six it's almost like oh I
don't know a pattern a pattern modeled
after God in the creation week and that
was my point Jeff are we really supposed
to believe preparation day for Israel
was intrinsically tied to day six
because day six is called Friday no this
was modeled after God's pattern in
creation which is why getting bogged
down in the names of the days distracts
away from the point and I said what I
did what I claimed is biblical Jeff
there is a pattern in that first week
Adam and Eve were prepared and fashioned
on day six to then enter into Holy
Communion with God on their first day of
existence which circles us right back to
why I also pointed out that Adam and
Eve's first day would have been the
seventh day of the week in the
importance of this detail it's not
arbitrary it's not just a passby fly
over detail you can learn something from
this as I primarily focused on in part
one Mr dowel has a really bad habit of
read in into things that were said but
not actually listening to why they were
said I've lost count of how many times
he's done this so far but since we're on
the subject Jeff let's look at something
from your spiritual forefather since you
wanted to try and act like you
Faithfully examined some of mine William
Miller's 1841 book views of the
prophecies and prophetic chronology is a
collection of Miller's sermons as well
as his interpretation of various verses
of scripture where he utilized his 13
rules of Bible interpretation as I've
shown before the SDA church signs off on
these 13 rules and upholds them to this
day well notice what Miller writes in a
manuscript titled lecture on the great
Sabbath where he's interpreting Ezekiel
2012 a verse that sdas love to throw out
constantly when it comes to the Sabbath
bit of a long one here but pay very
close attention quote this text is but a
recapitulation of one in Exodus 31:13
and is repeated Again by The Prophet
Ezekiel in verse 20 you will take notice
that it is a sign between God and the
children of Israel forever see Exodus
31:17 it is a sign between me and the
children of Israel forever for in 6 days
the Lord made Heaven and Earth and on
the seventh day he rested and was
refreshed it is also a Perpetual
Covenant see verse 16 now I want you
should observe that this sabbath was the
seventh day Sabbath God calls it my
Sabbath and shows his reason why for in
six days the Lord made Heaven and Earth
and on the seventh day he rested and was
refreshed he engrafted it then into the
de L and it was written upon both tables
of testimony showing clearly that it
would be binding under the gospel as
well as under the law see Verse 18 and
he gave unto Moses when he had made an
end of communing with him upon Mount Si
two tables of testimony tables of stone
written with the Finger of God and it's
being contained in the ten commands
written by the Finger of God on both
tables of the testimony Graven on Stone
to be a sign forever and a Perpetual
Covenant proves in my opinion beyond the
shadow of a doubt that it is binding
upon the Christian church as upon the
Jewish and in the same manner and for
the same reasons six days may work be
done but in the seventh is the Sabbath
of rest holy to the Lord this was the
manner close quote so this was the
opening of the lecture where he then
transitions into making application of
what he just said in a number of points
notice the first one quote we shall
inquire whether the seventh or the first
day of the week ought to be kept as a
Sabbath I say the the first for two
reasons one is Christ's resurrection and
is often meeting with his disciples
afterwards on that day this with the
example of the Apostles is strong
evidence that the proper creation
Sabbath to man came on the first day of
the week for Adam must have rested on
the first day after his creation he
being the last work of God and then God
rested Adam must have rested on the
first day of his life and thus you will
see that to Adam it was the first day of
the week for it would not be reasonable
to suppose that Adam began to reckon
time before he was created he certainly
could not be able to work six days
before the first Sabbath and thus with
the second Adam the first day of the
week he arose and lived and we find by
the Bible and by history that the first
day of the week was ever afterwards
observed as a day of worship close quote
uhoh Jeff William Miller was advocating
for the first day Sabbath and he arrived
at this conclusion
based on applying his 13 rules of
interpretation and it had nothing to do
with tradition or the pope he only used
his Bible the SDA Church tells us and
what else did he recognize that Adam and
Eve's first day was the seventh day of
the week that Adam wouldn't have been
able to work for six days before his
first Sabbath because he didn't exist
for six days before the first Sabbath in
creation even an uneducated untrained
19th century American Farmer was able to
see see what I'm saying Jeff so maybe
relay that to all of your Fanboys who
keep contacting us claiming that what I
put forth is totally confusing and
illogical no it's only confusing and
illogical if you listen to Mr dowel and
his straw man representation of what I
have claimed which is ultimately no
different than what we just read from Mr
Miller so now their own spiritual
forefather who gave them their
principles of interpreting the Bible no
he was totally confused
apparently the SDA Church tells us that
Miller just used literal Common Sense
along with the Bible and his 13 rules of
interpretation remember in the February
8 1979 issue of the review and Herald
they write quote Miller worked out
practical rules for the study of the
scripture called Miller's rules of Bible
interpretation these rules grew out of
the basic belief that the Bible is the
Christian's sole Authority for belief
and practice and that the scriptures are
self-authenticating and unified as well
as their own best Expositor he believed
that they should be understood in the
most obious and practical sense unless
there is a reason from the text itself
to believe a symbol a parable a figure
of speech or other literary form is
being
used these simple rules and an
acceptance of biblical Authority form
the foundation upon which the millerites
built their Temple of biblical truth in
the 1830s and 1840s even though some
errors of interpretation crept into
their construction of this Temple these
rules also became the foundation upon
which the emerging 7th Day Adventist
Church built its temple of Bible truth
the leaders of this developing movement
corrected errors in the interpretation
of the millerites and went on to
construct a complete system of Bible
teachings in fact there would be no
basis for the existence of the remnant
Church except for its Reliance upon
scripture as the final authority of
faith and practice close quote now
Adventists can claim that this is one of
the errors that crept into the millerite
temple that God corrected later through
Ellen White but this is just cope they
primarily have his false date setting in
mind here and stuff about eschatology
but either way it doesn't change the
fact that when using his rules of
interpretation he arrived at the same
fundamental position as Christian sabari
albeit he didn't use the same path to
get there Ellen White also endorsed this
book by the way along with Miller's
rules she writes quote The Light Of
Truth is going forth like a burning lamp
and those who love the light will not
walk in darkness they will study the
scriptures that they may know of
assurity that they are listening to the
voice of the true Shepherd and not that
of a stranger those who are engaged in
proclaiming the third Angel's message
are searching the scriptures upon the
same plan that father Miller adopted in
the little book entitled views of the
prophecies and prophetic chronology
father Miller gives the following simple
but intelligent and important rules for
Bible study and interpretation close
quote and she then goes on to list five
of his 13 rules but she claimed that
those who were engaged in proclaiming
the Adventist Church's third Angel's
message the warning about Sunday keeping
being the mark of the beast they need to
be searching the scriptures upon the
same plan that father Miller adopted in
his book then to top it all off in
spiritual gifts volume one Ellen White
provides one of the reasons that this
method of interpretation should be used
by Adventists in chapter 22 which is
titled William Miller she writes quote I
saw that God sent his Angel to move upon
the heart of a farmer who had not
believed the Bible and led him to search
the prophecies angels of God repeatedly
visited that chosen one and guided his
mind and opened his understanding to
prophecies which had ever been dark to
God's people the commencement of the
chain of Truth was given him and he was
led on to search for link after link
until he looked with Wonder and
admiration upon the word of God close
quote so she claimed to be shown in
vision from God that an angel of God
repeatedly visited William Miller
guiding his mind and opening his
understanding of scripture and more
specifically how to interpret the Bible
which is to say the 13 rules allegedly
come from God himself so Jeff in an
instance of sheer irony your propheus by
way of vision tacitly endorsed my
position by endorsing Miller's rules of
interpretation saying they came from God
which he used and arrived at my position
whoops now he obviously didn't arrive at
the same uh using the same method that
uh Christian sabari used to arrive at
this belief but it does show that even
the SDA Church's spiritual father using
their own interpretive principles also
arrived at this conclusion which shows
us that even broken clocks are right
twice a day but something else I want to
mention about the creation week being a
pattern and the importance that plays in
understanding the Sabbath for those
unaware Nicholas bound was an English
Puritan Theologian he was known
specifically for his extensive work on
the doctrine of the Sabbath now I am
citing Dr bound not because him saying
something makes it true but for the same
reason you go to a brain surgeon when
you need specialized Medical Care and
not a dentist notice what he says
regarding the pattern that's given in
the creation week and it's tied to the
fourth Commandment Under The Heading the
seventh day Comm commanded both under
the law and the gospel he writes quote
so he makes the seventh day to be genus
in this commandment and to be perpetual
and in it by virtue of the Commandment
to comprehend these two species or kinds
the Sabbath of the Jews and of the
Gentiles of the law and of the Gospel so
that both of them were comprehended in
the Commandment even as a Genus
comprehends both its species and so in
saying that both of them were inculcated
in the Commandment we do not imply
contradictions as though if it were
commanded the other not be but according
to the rules of logic we make the
general to include both the particulars
according to the rules of Reason close
quote all right so I want to take this
in bite-size chunks since this is a
classic work and the wording might not
be as easily understood for the modern
reader especially if you're not very
familiar with the subject the Christian
Sabbath position whether you agree with
it or not states that the Sabbath is a
Perpetual obligation both in the old
creation as well as in the new both
under the law and under the gospel and
the argument as bound has been laying
out up to this point in the book is not
that the Commandment has changed in its
substance he uses the term genus here
which if you recall from biology class
it refers to a parent family and within
that genus you have varying species so
simply put both the old creation form as
well as the new creation form are both
contained within the single commandment
and there's no contradiction
in other words this is the same thing we
saw William Miller say only in a more
sophisticated
manner bound then continues by
explaining quote where unto very fitly
may be adjoined as a further proof of it
saying of St Augustine who writing
against the manes he answered thus the
doctrine that they taught was not
diverse one from the other but the day
and time which Christ appointed was
diverse from that which Moses had taught
so that we have not in the gospel a new
commandment for the Sabbath diver from
what was in the law but there is a
diverse time appointed namely not the
seventh day from creation but the day of
Christ's resurrection and the seventh
from that both of them at several times
being comprehended in the fourth
Commandment and therefore Dr folk in his
confutation with the Remis says thus of
it in the scriptures the apostles knew
the one day of seven was appointed to be
observed forever during the world though
the prescribed day according to the law
was abrogated close quote and all of the
heads of the sdas in the audience just
exploded so why did bound bring up
Augustine's controversy with the manans
as well as Folk controversy with the
remist for those that do not know the
manans were a heretical sect in the 3r
century they were heretical for a number
of reasons but one of the key ones was
that they tried to set Moses against
Christ claiming that the two
contradicted one another that if you
uphold one you must denounce the other
they claimed that there was one
tradition of Moses when it came to the
Sabbath and another that contradicted it
regarding Christ so bound mentions
Augustine here because his response to
the manans was spoton Jesus and Moses
were not in contradiction to one another
not even on the Sabbath The Day and The
Time of the Sabbath in the gospel is
diverse from that of the Mosaic age but
this doesn't mean that Jesus
contradicted Moses which is also why he
cites William Folk's dispute with the
Remish new testament which was a Roman
Catholic translation of the New
Testament his point being Jesus entering
his rest a new day in the New Creation
in no way contradicts the law and the
prophets the substance of the
Commandment has not changed in the
slightest like I talked about back in
great detail in part
one but then the final part here quote
they knew it by scripture and what
scripture is more plain for it than this
commandment and the equity of it so that
the eighth or ninth day may not now be
observed in the time of the Gospel no
more than that it might be under the law
both of them being alike included in the
Commandment as we have heard that is as
the Learned expound it in the genus of
the law and in the substance of the law
which made the apostles to know to know
I say by the scriptures close quote and
this is another example on top of Exodus
16 on why I said Genesis doesn't say
Saturday or Sunday Jeff because the
creation week is a pattern you cannot
like this all you want but it's true and
Christian sabbatarians have not changed
that pattern We corporately Gather every
seven days from the that Jesus entered
his rest after accomplishing Redemption
which is bound's entire point he also
reiterates the same thing we looked at
from renowned church historian Philip
schof back in part one corporate first
day worship started with who the
apostles which is yet another evidence
that Jeff is misrepresenting Me by
claiming that Christian sabbatarians
believe and teach that there was a first
day Sunday Sabbath in Genesis it also
further evidences that Jeff didn't
actually listen to what my chart is
representing and has given his viewers
his own spin on such all of his
questions were predicated on a
misrepresentation of why I said Saturday
and Sunday are not mentioned in the text
it had nothing to do with denying or
rejecting a single creation week of
seven days or six days of creation and
one day rest however you want to word it
and he didn't disprove my biblical
evidence that the creation week is a
pattern so Jeff cannot like this he can
huff and puff all he wants and keep
lying about Christians but it won't
change the facts we arrive at our belief
on this from scripture and by way of the
Apostles you don't have to agree but
when you guys claim that this is
something involving the pope and the
traditions of men you simply dismiss
yourself from any serious dialogue and
you evidence that all you care about is
grandstanding your own tradition and
rallying sdas together because you have
yet to even hear this guy meaningfully
engage with the Christian sabari
position you know miles Cherry picks
early church fathers these guys love to
go to the early church fathers Justin
Martyr tulan Ignatius they love to go to
all these Church fathers Clement of
Alexandria you know Barnabas they love
all these Church fathers miles loves to
to quote these early church fathers for
keeping
Sunday so guess what we're going to go
to the church fathers
okay we're going to look at testimony of
the early church fathers the father that
these critics love to quote but you know
what they only quote a little bit of
what these guys say there's a whole
bunch of stuff they say that these guys
don't even quote but we're going to
quote a statement by Justin Martyr
tonight now watch this here's Justin
Martyr they love to quote Justin
Martyr and here's what Justin Martyr
says Sunday is the day on which we all
hold our common assembly see they look
at that wow they all come together on
Sunday this is what the church father
Justin Martyr says let's read it
carefully Sunday is the day on which we
all hold our common assembly because it
is the first day on which God having
wrought a change in the darkness in
matter made the world and Jesus Christ
Our Savior on the same day rose from the
dead does miles agree with this church
father he quotes him all the
time where did Justin martyr get this
idea about Sunday the first day of the
week where did he get that
idea did he get it from the first week
of
creation did he get it from the week in
the old
creation does this Sunday as the first
day of the week in the old
creation still stand today is the same
Sunday the first day of the week in the
new creation
if it does not why not now remember
miles wants to talk about this new
creation and we're going to get into
that in the next few videos this new
creation so if not why not now on the
other hand if it does then nothing has
changed at all in the first week of
creation even till
now so if it does if it doesn't he's
going to have to answer these question
questions now I'm going to tell you
right from the start that the critics
are not going to answer these questions
especially they don't even watch the
whole video I've watched their whole
videos from the beginning to the end
when I watch Sam and I watch Miles I
started and I watched the whole thing
but guess what they're not going to
watch this whole video they're going to
tap in and tap out troll in and TR out
but they're not going to sit down write
the answers out to the questions I'm
asking see because if they were to ever
convert me to what they believe they're
going to have to answer my questions
they're not the ones that's going to run
the whole show all the time no they're
going to have to answer my
questions yeah this aged like milk Jeff
because not only have I gone through the
painful process of forcing myself to
listen to your driil I've listened
through multiple times to the detriment
of my IQ this is just cope on Jeff's
part trying to overcompensate and
convince himself that he's achieving
something of grandeur because as can be
seen in part one and tonight I not only
answered his supposed hard-hitting
questions very easily but I also
demonstrated why they're not even valid
because this entire presentation is
built on Straw Men and
misrepresentations that he has concocted
up in his own mind and then pedal out to
his audience so they can all glaze each
other in their Echo chamber but it's
also funny that he says I'm not going to
answer the questions when Jeff you
haven't engaged with a lick of the
biblical Arguments for my position you
erected all sorts of straw men like
pointing to the church fathers and so
see it's just the church fathers
dismissing Philip kaser because he has
degrees and anything but engage with the
biblical argumentation because you can't
you don't even know the arguments as you
yourself have demonstrated nevertheless
yeah Jeff I sometimes cite the church
fathers what's your
point and Advent toite Ellen White
constantly the difference is I don't
make the in claims about the fathers
that your organization does about Ellen
White nor did the fathers make such
insane claims about themselves like
Ellen White did for
herself this criticism is just silly and
desperate for starters I didn't site a
single Bill a single one of them as the
basis for my position I presented
biblical arguments Jeff as did Philip
caser John's Parker and the various
other individuals that we looked at
arguments that you haven't even bothered
to address and I think we know why
secondly I didn't cite Justin Martyr in
my presentation in fact I hardly ever
cite him at all so where are you getting
this idea that I cite him all the time
aside from in your
imagination thirdly Jeff you entirely
misrepresented why I cite the fathers
when I do I cite the Fathers as
historical sources not to say well look
they believed it so therefore it's true
such as when his prophetess aant claimed
that the pope changed the Sabbath which
is totally ahistorical fiction Jeff
himself is going to end up proving this
shortly in his own attempt to utilize
the church fathers to try and refute
what he thinks my position is the
arguments for my position come from
scripture I've only ever cited the
fathers in this area when demonstrating
historical claims Jeff citing Justin
Martyr to say see he used the word
Sunday to refer to the first day in
Genesis as if that somehow refutes the
point I made about Genesis not saying
Saturday or Sunday that only proves that
you didn't listen to my presentation
learn even if you disagree you listened
for what you think could be gotcha
moments and then fourthly Jeff you once
again misrepresented the doctrine of the
new creation I never claimed that the
new creation changed the order of the
weekly cycle this is whole cloth him
making things up again but as for the
claim that I cherry-picked the fathers
Jeff I'll do you one better how's about
you come on to answering adventism and
we'll test this claim and discuss the
Theology and doctrine of the church
fathers and see who is and isn't
cherry-picking them okay it's awfully
ironic that he says this when we're
about to see him do this exact
thing now let's read a little deeper
into what Justin Martyr actually says
because they stopped right at the idea
of
Sunday they came together all right so
let's read it
Sunday look at the Highlight in red
Sunday it is the first day God made the
world and Jesus on the same day rose
from the dead so what do we have the
critics like miles and a host of others
go to Justin Martyr to prove their
Sunday no and I'm going to correct this
lie every time he says it every single
argument I have for the first day
Sabbath is from scripture you haven't
disproven or dealt with a single one of
them Jeff and I think we know why I only
ever cite the fathers in this area to
refute historical claims that the SDA
pioneers and Pope Ellen made about
history like the juvenile conspiracy
that the pope changed the
Sabbath according to Justin Martyr
Sunday's the first day of the week and
in the first day of the week of
creation so in God's first week of
creation according to this church father
Justin Martyr Sunday is the first day of
the week there it is right
there watch
carefully Justin
Martyr Church Father that Miles loves to
quote
refers to Sunday the first day the same
day Jesus rose from the dead is the day
and first day in which God made the
world so you go to Genesis and find out
what the first day was that God made the
world right and Justin Martyr called
that day
Sunday right and Jeff the only reason
you think this is some sort of gotcha is
because you entirely misrepresented me I
never claimed that the new creation
brings about a new weekly cycle I nevera
claimed that there's multiple varying
weekly cycles that isn't what my chart
was conveying either which is evidenced
in my own explanation of what the chart
is depicting and when I said the words
Saturday and Sunday aren't used in
Genesis I also explained what I meant by
that but what's funny Jeff is you just
got done accusing me of cherry-picking
and Justin Martyr calling the first day
in Genesis Sunday is supposed to prove
it yet you cherry-picked just in
yourself in doing so why the unjust
weights and measures furthermore we have
an article on our website compiling what
some of the church fathers said in this
area to Simply document the historical
record over and against the ahistorical
lies of the evst church under one of the
quotes from Justin's dialogue with Trio
what do I
write that Justin believed Sunday is the
first of all days which further proves
that Jeff is misrepresenting what I
meant when I said the words Saturday and
Sunday are not found in the Bible and
the fact that he thinks Justin's
position is out of sync with mine only
proves Jeff's own lack of familiarity
with both Justin and the position he's
seeking to refute the Christian Sabbath
however Jeff I do appreciate you reading
this statement from Justin because it's
a piece of the historical evidence that
your prophetess wasn't shown by God that
the pope changed the Sabbath again like
I showed earlier Jeff's Prophet is
claimed to be shown by God that the pope
changed the Sabbath from Saturday to
Sunday meaning corporate worship of the
Christian church on the first day is
allegedly a product of the papacy yet
Justin lived centuries before any such a
concept was even a viable reality even
if we wanted to Grant the historical
claims of the Roman Catholic Church to
the papacy being traced back to Peter
something I obviously do not agree with
the time frame in which Justin Martyr
lived was not a time when such an office
would have had the level of notoriety
and power to be able to do such a global
change in both the East and the West
well Ellen White claimed that the papacy
was set up in 538 ad that's supposed to
be the start date for them to get their
timeline from Daniel 7 25 about the pope
Changing Times and laws and then after
1260 years from 538 they land on
1798 which is the year they claim the
end times began and the papacy received
its deadly wound so 538 as a start date
for the papacy is baked into the SDA
cake folks Justin Martyr lived in the 2
century and was writing around 150 ad
the quote that Jeff read from Justin is
his dialogue with Trio the Jew where
Justin is explaining various aspects of
the New Covenant Church in
contradistinction to the old Covenant
people of God and corporate first day
worship was one of those things which
means corporate Worship On the first day
was taking place universally in both the
East and the West in the church long
before when Ellen White says the papacy
came to be so Jeff all you proved with
this quote is that your prophetess was a
lousy historian that wasn't shown by God
that the pope quote unquote changed the
Sabbath especially considering her
historical presentation in this area is
supposed to be coming from God himself
she was shown these things this is why I
cite the church fathers they are
historical sources that prove your
guys's great controversy reimagining of
history is exactly that a reimagining of
reality that's what he called it
tulan the
Sabbath
Saturday now I didn't make this up tulan
was born about 160 and then went to 220
ad I didn't make this up tertullian they
love to quote tertullian they love to
quote the church fathers right by the
way he was a Latin father not Greek
father and he refers to the Sabbath as
what
day
Saturday now they're basing this on
creation on creation according to
tulan Saturday is the seventh day of the
week in the first week of creation so in
God's first week of creation according
to this church father tertullian
Saturday is the seventh day of the week
now what day do s 7 Day Adventist says
the
Sabbath
Saturday
correct again Jeff it's sad that you
think this is some sort of gotcha but
once again it's only because you built
this entire presentation on rudimentary
level understanding remember folks Jeff
is telling people that Christian sabari
believe their there was a first day
Sunday Sabbath in creation which is
false I've shown this I don't even know
how many times in both part one and
tonight launching off of this error he
then incorrectly quote mind my
presentation where I said the biblical
text doesn't say Saturday or Sunday he
misquoted me and left off that I said it
doesn't say Saturday or Sunday which
disproves his straw man that I claimed
there's a first day Sunday Sabbath in
Genesis Building on both of those errors
he now claimed I cherry-picked the
church fathers for my support despite me
not citing the church fathers for the
reason that he claimed Jeff is the one
cherry-picking and he's free to come on
here like I said and we'll have a
discussion and see who is and isn't
cherry-picking the fathers now we hear
him cite the church fathers referring to
the first day is Sunday and the seventh
day is Saturday and that's supposed to
disprove what I said about Sunday and
Saturday not being found in the biblical
text a statement that I clarified in the
presentation that he's critiquing as
well as tonight
Jeff you should be embarrassed and
ashamed of yourself unfortunately based
on what we've heard from you thus far
you are a victim of Dunning Krueger
which is a silent killer for those
unaware the Dunning Krueger effect is a
cognitive bias where a person thinks
they know more than they do on a subject
but they're not bright enough to realize
that they don't know as much as they
think they
do but there's a lot we can learn from
this which is why we're dedicating the
time to responding Jeff can Bo and scoff
but lots and lots of of Adventist have
been redpilled on the Christian Sabbath
due to the efforts of this platform they
didn't come to these silly conclusions
that Jeff did in his attempt to try and
make me look ridiculous and Confused
these folks were genuine Seekers who
listened carefully analyzed the biblical
case that was made and came to the
conclusion that it's biblical so Jeff
keep up this silly charade to generate
clicks off our platform's name like a
sycophant keep making these reputations
that only glaze the Ardent died in the
wool amongst your RS
but the honest listener who heeds the
Bible's advice of hearing both sides of
a matter before arriving at the
conclusion is going to very easily see
how badly you misrepresented my position
to such a degree that one has to ask if
it was intentional but nevertheless we
will pick back up where we left off in
part three May Christ richly bless you
all in the grace and peace won by him
and his vicarious death on the cross for
Sinners until next time God
bless ho to apostate
did he say
that come on man